[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur tv78 nous sommes le
lundi 6 novembre voici le programme de
ce soir chaque année des milliers de
fumeurs tentent d'arrêter la cigarette à
l'occasion du mois sans tabac patch
pastille cigarette électronique
plusieurs astuces peuvent aider à
arrêter de fumer quelles sont vos
méthodes nous sommes allés vous poser la
question nous parlerons également des
solutions avec Louis josran le président
de l'association alliance contre le
tabac c'est l'invité du 78 à quelques
mois des Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024
l'ambiance était au rendez-vous au
Vélodrome national de Saint-Quentin en
yeline samedi dernier le site olympique
accueiller l'UCI track Champions League
il s'agit d'une compétition de cyclisme
surpist qui rassemble des coureurs du
monde en entier vitesse endurance les
visiteurs ont assisté à un véritable
spectacle ils étaient 620 courageux à
affronter la pluie hier matin pour
participer à la 10e édition de la course
royale reliant versaill à Fontenel
lefleuri cette année une particularité
un semimarathon pour les Jeux Olympiques
de Paris
2024 mais tout de suite on va faire le
point sur les informations à retenir
aujourd'hui dans les
ivlines
et c'est avec vous Grégory canalé
bonsoir bonsoir Mathilde hier Gérald
armanin le ministre de l'Intérieur a
annoncé qu'il y avait eu 1000 actes
antisémites commis en France depuis le
début de la guerre entre Israël et le
Hamas quelle est la situation dans les
Yveline greégori les répercussions du
conflit se ressentent également dans le
département pas de chiffr néanmoins à
vous donner la préfecture des ivelines
ne souhaite pas communiquer sur le sujet
de son côté l'association juif de morpa
et ses environs que nous avons contacté
continue de recenser des actes
antisémites mais ne constate aucune
hausse particulière dans les Yvelines en
revanche l'association confie une
inquiétude et un sentiment d'insécurité
de plus en plus important et parmi les
victimes de ces actes antisémites l'
villinoise yilbron Pivet la présidente
de l'Assemblée nationale a porté plainte
après la réception d'un nouveau courrier
antisémite adressé à sa permanence de la
5e circonscription interrogé par nos
confrères du Parisien son entourage
indique qu'elle aurait déjà reçu une
vingtaine qu'elle aurait déjà déposé une
vingtaine de plaintes à ce sujet cette
année et les agressions à l'encontre des
élus persistent dans le département
puisque Carl oleve a lui aussi déposé
plainte la semaine dernière le député
renaissance de la 12e circonscription a
également déposé plainte à la suite de
menace de mort proféré à son encontre
sur le réseau social x ex Twitter et
dans des posts publiés par des comptes
anonymes le parlementaire est représenté
face à un individu armé d'un couteau ou
encore dans un sac plastique au milieu
d'un cimetière après une interpellation
jeudi l'affaire a été classée sensite
vendredi un jour un de nous y passera a
tweetter l'ancien maire de poissie
toujours sur le réseau social d'X et à
guillancour le Golf National de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline a une nouvelle
fois été saccagé il a été pris pour
siible ce site olympique par des
activistes dans la nuit de vendredi à
samedi une partie du Green du trou
numéro 8 a été ravagé par des coup de
pioche le rendant impraticable les
dégâts s'élèvent à près de 2000 € des
inscriptions ont aussi été retrouvé sur
le parcours parmi elles je cite 220 km
Carr pour les golfs et 0 km Carr pour la
biodiversité ou encore ils construisent
des golfs nous voulons des forêts fin de
citation en 2022 le golf national avait
déjà été visé par une action du groupe
extinction rebellion et contacté par
notre rédaction le directeur du site
Philippe Pilato n'a pas souhaité
commenter ses actes et bien merci
beaucoup Grégory Canel pour toutes ces
informations et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi vous voyez une information ou une
image près de chez vous qui vous a
marqué n'hésitez pas à nous la
communiquer sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 7we
news pendant 30 jours 146000 français
vont tenter d'arrêter de fumer en
novembre c'est le traditionnel mois sans
tabac l'an dernier plus de 3000
evvelinois ont tenté de relever le défi
pour y parvenir certains se tourne vers
des moyens de substitution comme la
cigarette électronique c'est le
reportage de Patrick Jacques de Dixmude
et de Enzo alemo ils sont près de 150000
inscrits cette année pour relever le
défi du mois sans tabac depuis 2016
chaque mois de novembre est consacré à
cette opération qui a été suivie par 1,2
million de personnes depuis sa création
oui je suis inscrit sur le mois sans
tabac ma fille m'a envoyé et donc voilà
il va falloir que je me'y mette c'est
bien sensibiliser les gens et surtout
les jeunes parce que bah beaucoup de
gens fument c'est très mauvais c'est
très bien mais il faut que les fumeurs
l'appliquent ou i non c'est bien c'est
bien je pense qu' il faut faire ce genre
d'opération voilà pour sensibiliser les
gens pour moi je dis ça sert à rien
pourquoi parce que bon celui qui fume il
fumera en permanent même tous les
traitements médicaux qu'on a ne servent
pour moi pas grandchose non pas
forcément c'est quelque chose que je
vais pouvoir faire de moi-même mais pas
forcément sur l'initiative du mois Sant
tabac arrêter de fumer pendant 30 jours
multiplie par 5 les chances de stopper
définitivement parmi les alternatives la
cigarette électronique ce commerçant
inimontain constate une augmentation des
ventes Chac année au moment de
l'opération mois sans tabac oui il y
aura toujours des nouveaux clients grâce
au mois sans tabac et à cause de la
cigarette et grâce au mois sans tabac en
quantifiant on va vous dire que on va
générer peut-être 50 % de nouveaux
clients mais essentiellement venu grâce
au mois sans tabac franchement sans
lavapte je pense j'y serais pas arrivé
j'ai essayé les pâes j'ai essayé les
gommes parce que quand on est quand on
est infirmier on a accès à tout ça donc
c'est plus facile à l'hôpital j'ai
essayé mais ça a pas fonctionné j'ai
essayé les patchs donc j'ai arrêté mais
le manque revient très très vite donc
c'est vraiment un très très bon
compromis surtout quand on vous guide
bien ne contenant pas de tabac la
cigarette électronique pourrait
constituer une aide pour arrêter de
fumer mais les bénéfices et risques sont
encore méconnus des recherches
scientifiques ont révélé la présence de
métau lourd dans les vapoteuses le mois
sans tabac qui a débuté depuis le 1er
novembre vous accompagnera par d'autres
solutions conseil quotidien qui d'aide
et échange avec des professionnels de
santé l'an dernier plus de 3000
zivelinois ont tenté de relever le défi
allez c'est l'heure de parler sport à
présent dans votre
[Musique]
78 et on débute cette page sportive
Grégory avec l'événement sportif du
weekend c'était samedi dernier au
Vélodrome national et pour la deuxième
fois de son histoire lescin
cinquantinois accueillé une étape de
l'UCI track Champions League 76 coureurs
ont participé à cette compétition de
cyclisme sur piste qui se se déroule sur
C manch C manches aux quatre coins de
l'Europe et même si les Français n'ont
pas brillé l'ambiance était au
rendez-vous dans les tribunes du site
qui va accueillir des épreuves des Jeux
olympiques de Paris
[Musique]
2024 ambiance des grands soirs au
Vélodrome national après maork et Berlin
l'UCI tr Champions League a fait étape à
50 ans en Eveline pour la 3è manche
quelques grand nom du cyclisme sur piste
féminin et masculin s'affronai sur
quatre épreuves du sprint et de
l'endurance le tout pendant une soirée
l'objectif pour les organisateurs offrir
du spectacle au public réinventer la
manière dont on présente le cyclisme sur
piste au public en essayant de le
simplifier au maximum et de le rendre de
plus en plus spectaculaire à quelques
mois desg la ferveur olympique s'est
ressentie dans les gradins cinquantinois
près de 3900 spectateurs ont assisté à
la compétition au Vélodrome site de
paris 2024 laaffluence a presque doublé
par rapport à l'édition de l'année
dernière pour les gios ça m'a semblait
compliqué de venir donc je j'ai profité
de cette réunion pour venir là moi
j'aime beaucoup ce type de format parce
que c'est un vrai spectacle et il y a
une vraie compétition on fait de la
piste aussi à Saint-Quentin donc voir
les les pros rouler beaucoup plus que
nous c'est c'est plutôt cool aussi côté
français pas de Marie divine kam ni de
Mathilde gros vainqueur de la Champions
League l'an passé trois bleus étaient
engagé sans obtenir de résultats
probants devant leur public Quentin
lafar termine dernier du scratch et 13e
de la course par élimination le champion
du monde 2019 du kilomètre a commencé
depuis peu sa mutation de la vitesse
vers les épreuves d'endurance je suis
venu parce que parce que je trouvais ça
intéressant je me suis dit que dans dans
l'idée ça allait animer un peu ma prépa
hivernale et que ça allait pouvoir me
faire faire des des efforts en
compétition qui étai plus agréable plus
décevant en revanche pour les Français
engagés dans les épreuves de vitesse
melvin landerno et Tom de rche ont été
éliminé dès le premier tour du sprint et
du Kin un peu déçu forcément parce que
on veut toujours faire mieux devant
devant devant son public mais je sais je
sais que je travaille beaucoup en ce
moment donc je peux pas non plus espérer
travailler fort la semaine et être fort
le le le le weekend l'objectif c'est
voilà courir prendre de l'expérience se
faire aussi plaisir c'est un peu dur
forcément quand se fait sortir mais il
faut garder ça en tête pour les
prochains matchs au classement général
du sprint dominé par le néerlandais la
vraie scène Tom de rash perd sa 3è place
il compte désormais 16 points de retard
sur le podium l'UCI track Champions
League s'achève les 10 et 11 novembre
prochains deux dernières étapes au
programme à Londres autre grand
événement sportif la 30e édition de la
Transat jacquesevabre à la course de
voile transatlantique en duo ça y est
les skipeur de la catégorie imoka vont
pouvoir prendre la mer oui après les
Ocean y et la classe 40 les équipages de
la catégorie imoka partiront demain du
port du Havre direction la Martinique le
départ prévu le 29 octobre dernier avait
dû être reporté à cause des tempêtes
kiaran et Domingos conséquence pour
cette catégorie donc vous voyez le
parcours en noir sur la carte le tracé
et réduit passant de
5400000 à
3765000 m000 les bateaux laisseront à
tribor l'archipel des assorts on
rappelle que deux ivelinois participent
dans la catégorie MOCA le rambolitin
Louis Burton fait équipe avec Davy
baudar sur bureau Vallé il participe à
sa 7e transat jacqu Vabre il s'agit en
revanche d'une deuxième participation
pour l'autre représentant du département
Éric Bellon le versaillais aura
l'occasion de tester son tout nouveau
bateteau sur la course il est lui avec
Martin le PAP sur stand as one départ
prévu donc ce mardi matin aux alentours
mathil de 4 5h du matin il faudra mettre
son son réveil très tôt ou c'est un peu
tôt on poursuit ces actualités sportives
avec quelques résultats et on commence
avec du rugby dans le championnat de
fédéral 2 le Rugby Club de Versailles
affronttit hier le de 2è du classement
de la poule 8 saint-malot et pour cette
6e journée le club versaillais n'a pas
réussi à gagner à domicile s'incline et
s'incline 30 34 à 21 le bon score c'est
bien sûr 34 à 21 on va regarder tout de
suite le résumé de la rencontre avec
Clara de Frutos et Mélanie
pocket de l'intensité les Versaillais 7e
de leur pou savait que face à saintmo 2e
il en fallait une stratégie plutôt
payante sur la première -emps même si
les Malouins marquent deux essais les
Versaillais en inscrivent un seul score
à la posuse 14 à 17 en faveur des
visiteurs le rythme l'enchaînement des
tâches ça fonctionnait très bien je
pense qu'on les a surpris aussi
peut-être qu'il nous attendait pas à ce
niveau-là on savait que cétait une
équipe qui était très dense qu'on allait
devoir nous déplacer le ballon
énormément avec beaucoup de mouvement
beaucoup de replacement au retour des
vestiaires les Versaillais sont
régulièrement sanctionnés saint-malot
prend le large des pénalités et un
nouvel essai
Versailles marque aussi après un
longtemps fort mais l'écart est trop
important score final 34 à 21 pour les
maloins dans la cité royale c'est la
frustration qui règne déçu puisque on
repart pas avec un point de bonus au
moins donc je pense que sur la première
partie de de match on espérait quand
même un peu mieux voilà on a été mis un
petit peu en danger en 2uxème mi-temps
sur tout ce qui est jou au pied voilà
avec des des 5022 qui nous ont fait un
petit peu mal et qui nous ont laissé un
petit peu dans dans notre dans nos 22 m
donc on a eu du mal à à sortir de notre
camp donc voilà le score est est assez
logique à la finale falloir qu'on qu'on
apprenne on est tombé on est tombé sur
une équipe qui nous a qui nous a donné
une petite leçon de de rugby
stratégiquement et et au niveau du du
jeu au pied donc voilà va falloir
apprendre se reconcentrer très
rapidement après 6 journées versaill
comptabilise trois victoires et trois
défaites prochain match le 12 novembre
prochain face au reux 4e du classement
Versailles reste à la 7e place à 18
points du leader
[Applaudissements]
et toujours en rugby dans le même groupe
il y avait un derby yvelinois ce
dimanche le plaisir Rugby Club recevait
le MLS GP comprenait maison la fite
Saint-Germain onla poissi dans le cadre
de la 6e journée de fédéral 2 une
rencontre qui a largement tourné en la
faveur des Plaisirois victoire 36 à 13
plaisir qui est bon leader de sa poule
avec 7 points d'avant sur SaintMalo au
classement le M lsgp est à la 11e et
avant-dernière place du football à
présent la mauvaise série continue pour
Versailles en National c'est un 3è match
d'affilé sans victoire pour le club de
la cité royale vendredi les hommes de
Laurent Perlade se sont inclinés de buts
1 contre Dijon pour le compte de la 12e
journée du championnat les ivelinois
sont 12e et ne comptent désormais plus
qu'un seul point d'écart sur la zone
relégable ils auront l'occasion de se
refaire dès vendredi prochain avec la
réception de nî qui est 10e et toujours
en football mais dans le championnat de
régional 2 deux clubs du département se
faisaient face oui autre derby yvelinois
du weekend c'était donc dimanche en foot
dans le championnat de R2 trappe
l'emporte contre l'équipe réserve du FC
Manois 2-1 le score final les traapistes
6e se déplace à Suren dimanche prochain
lanterne rouge au classement de ce
groupe D de régional 2 pas de match en
revanche pour le FC Manois vous nous
parlez à présent de basket c'est
contrasté dans le championnat de
National 3 masculine dans la 8e journée
de la poule F deux défaites et une seule
petite victoire pour nos clubs du
département on commence avec la touche
positive succès de l'Entente le chîn
Versailles 75-71 contre biorel trappe
perd sur le parquet de Saint-Martin les
boulognes 84 à 77 le LCV 78
avant-dernier les trapppistes 11e sur 14
vont d'ailleurs se défier samedi
prochain à trappe enfin très courte
défaite pour la lanterne rouge au
classement Chatou un seul point d'écart
au final pour les Catoviens face à
Vernon le score 69 à 68 Chatou qui
accueillera Saint-Martin les boulognes
pour la prochaine journée samedi
prochain et chez les basketeuses pas de
victoire non plus hiérarchie respectée
dans ce championnat de National 2
féminine pour l'Entente le chîn
Versailles donc qui est 3e au classement
et qui se déplaçait sur le parquet du
leader Calais pour le compte de cette 7e
journée une défaite 53 à 47 le LCV 78
recevra samedi prochain le 7e neeville
en Ferin et on va parler de handbal
maintenant malheureusement encore une
défaite Mathilde en Nationale de
féminine décidément le weekend n pas été
très bon pour notre club ivlinois samedi
les joueuses de Montini le Bretonneau
ont perdu 37 à 25 contre saintem 3 le
défi était élevé pour les inimonages 8e
de lepool qui affrontait l'actuelle
dauphin du championnat elle rejoue dès
samedi prochain à domicile duel de
milieu de tableau face à tourcoin qui
est 7e beaucoup de défaites ce weekend
mais on va terminer ces actualités
sportives par un événement Royal un
événement royal et dans un cadre Pr
prestigieux ce dimanche avait lieu donc
la course royale à Versailles parcours
famille épreuve de 10 km ou même de 5 km
semi-marathon pour les plus aguéris
plusieurs centaines de coureurs se sont
réunis malgré l'appui pour cette 10e
édition reportage de Julien Leroi et de
Clara de
Frutos derniers échauffements avant le
grand départ 620 coureurs s'étaient
inscrit pour la 10e course royale ce
dimanche 5 novembre des parcours
réalisés entre Versailles et Fontenet le
fleurri à travers le patrimoine de ce
territoire historique pièce d'eau des
Suisses château du Roi Soleil et grand
canal ces sportifs avaient gardé un
moral d'acier pour sillonner les 10,5 km
malgré une météo capricieuse est-ce que
vous sentez prêt pour cette
course on essaye on essaye le le temps
est quand même difficile on se réchauffe
comme on peut en attendant mais hyper
motivé et a une bonne ambiance c'est
hyper sympa la ligne d'arrivée franchit
les sportifs laissent éclater leur
joieouilleux Gou non mais après il est
bien il y a quand même des bonneses par
contre est dur il y a enfin il y a quand
même des montées un peu la dernière est
un peu dure mais sinon ça va cette année
une particularité la course des 20 km
devient un semi-marathon trajet entre
route et trail un challenge recherché
par les coureurs expérimenter l'année
dernière j'avais fait le 10 km et cette
année le SMI là j'ai fait 1h32 je crois
1h32 il y avait des passages un peu
difficiles AVC de la boue avvec de le
temps les conditions climatiques elles
étaient pas étaient pas top on va dire
Johan obtient la médaille d'or sur ce
circuit avec un temps d'unh et 9 minutes
récompenses supplémentair entre 6 et 12
dossards seront remis aux participants
tirer au sort pour prendre part au 10 km
du marathon pour tous de Paris 2024 un
moment unique pour courir dans le
sillage des futurs athlètes olympiques
et bien merci beaucoup Grégory canalé
pour toutes ces informations sportives
c'est bientôt l'heure de passer à
l'invité du 78 mais avant je vous
propose de jeter un coup d'œil à la
météo de
demain
demain matin nous devrions avoir de
belles éclaircis sur l'ensemble des
Yvelines côté température il fera 7°gr à
Rambouillet et 8°gr à Houdan
mantelajolie et Versailles l'après-midi
le soleil sera toujours bien présent
dans le département compté 10°gr à
Rambouillet 11°gr à Oudan et Versailles
et 12°gr à mont-lajolie nous aurons
également un peu de vent alors
couvrez-vous bien et demain nous
fêterons la saintekarine c'est l'heure à
présent de passer à l'invité
[Musique]
78 30 jours pour arrêter de fumer c'est
le défi du mois sans tabac en France
près de 12 millions de personnes sont
fumeurs et près de 6 fumeurs sur 10
souhaitent arrêter pour en parler avec
nous louï josrand le président de
l'Alliance contre le tabac en visio avec
nous bonsoir bonsoir alors alors on
connaît tous les effets néfastes de la
cigarette du tabac lejos ran quelles
sont les méthodes les plus efficaces
pour arrêter de
fumer les méthodes les plus efficaces
consist il y en a deux principales ce
sont tout d'abord les substituts
nicotiniqu qui peuvent être accessibles
d'ailleurs sans prescription ou avec
prescription qui sont remboursé
aujourd'hui par la Sécurité Sociale et
les mutuel donc ça c'est une bonne chose
et puis il y a également les cigarettes
électroniques qui peuvent être utilisé
où là aussi il y a des résultats qui
sont à peu près comparables à ceux de la
substitution nicotinique c'est un choix
personnel certains vont préférer la
substitution les patchs les gommes ce
genre de choses d'autres vont préférer
la cigarette électronique voilà faut
être adapté à sa propre situation faut
s'adapter à la situation du patient pour
les professionnels qui vont prendre en
charge ces ces patients mais c'est
surtout une affaire de choix personnel
alors justement la cigarette
électronique on en parlait dans le
reportage juste avant en début
d'émission euh vous en pensez quoi vous
de la cigarette électronique c'est c'est
une bonne méthode c'est une bonne
stratégie pour
arrêter c'est c'est une stratégie qui a
à peu près les mêmes niveaux de réussite
que la que la substitution nicotinique
pardon donc oui qu' a de de de de bons
de bons résultats euh ce qu'il faut voir
c'est que en revanche dans une logique
de sevrage il faut savoir sortir de la
cigarette électronique c'estàdire que la
cigarette électronique dans une logique
d'arrêt c'est sur une période temporelle
quelques semaines quelques mois mais il
faut l'arrêter il s'agit pas de devenir
vapoteur sur le long terme puisque là on
sera exposé à d'autres risques qui ne
sont pas les mêmes que ceux du tabac qui
sont probablement inférieurs mais
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas quantifier
les risques auxquels expose la cigarette
électronique donc il est préférable de
dire qu'il vaut mieux l'arrêter plutôt
que de continuer à être exposé à quelque
chose qui sera dangereux pour C sé alors
être motivé pour arrêter de fumer ça me
semble primordial mais est-ce que c'est
suffisant puisque le tabac c'est c'est
c'est une
addiction alors le tabac c'est
effectivement une addiction une
addiction extrêmement forte extrêmement
puissante donc c'est pour ça également
que c'est difficile d'en sortir c'est
pour ça qu'il est difficile de de de se
sevrer tout simplement et c'est aussi
pour ça qu'il faut surtout ne pas
hésiter à se faire aider alors on peut à
l'occasion du mois sans tabac se faire
aider collectivement à travers l'énergie
qui va être déployée dans dans ce mois
sans tabac et puis il faut aussi ne pas
hésiter à aller demander conseil à un
professionnel de santé un tabacologue ça
peut être une infirmière tabacologue une
sage-femme tabacologue un médecin
tabacologue il y a pas de tout tout
toutes toutes les ces professions pour
certains d'entre eux ont été formé donc
et même son médecin généraliste peut
tout à fait prendre en charge peut
prendre en charge des des des patients
qui ont qui souhaitent se sevrer donc
faut surtout ne pas hésiter à aller
chercher de l'aide parce que c'est un
moment qui reste compliqué même quand on
est aidé même quand on a une
substitution ou une cigarette
électronique ça reste un é un une
période qui n'est pas complètement
simple il faut le reconnaître mais ça
n'est pas impossible c'est surtout ça
qu'il faut garder en tête et puis ce
sera peut-être pas ce mois novembre qui
sera sans tabac ça sera peut-être le
mois de décembre ou ça sera peut-être
janvier 2024 mais à partir du moment où
on rentre dans une dynamique positive de
sevrage c'est une marche en avant on ne
revient jamais en arrière et on
progresse progressivement vers l'arrêt
et on va finir à un moment ou à un autre
par s'arrêter c'est surtout ça qu'il
faut retenir et puis il y a également
faut en parler le 3989 qui est tabac
infos service qui est très mise en avant
à l'occasion du mois sans tabac c'est
aussi une occasion de l'utiliser pour
aller chercher de l'aide euh sur ce et
un soutien euh pendant ce mois sint
tabac oui le site internet moi Sabas
propose aussi des kits comme comme
celui-ci pour aider les fumeurs à
arrêter de fumer c'est des c'est des
outils importants il me semble qui aide
les fumeurs la plupart des fumeurs
fument par habitude après un café après
euh le déjeuner ou en soirée entre amis
comment est-ce qu'on peut réussir à se
défaire de ces
habitudes c'est ce qui est cette cette
habitude c'est effectivement quelque
chose qui est compliqué alors c'est pour
ça qu'il faut avoir une substitution
nicotinique quelle qu'elle soit euh déjà
pour au niveau du du sevrage biologique
être plus à l'aise et puis ensuite il va
falloir effectivement arriver à rompre
ses habitudes peut-être qu'au moment du
café bah il faudra peut-être prendre un
verre d'eau à la place d'un café euh
peut-être qu'il faudra changer un petit
peu ses habitudes à ce moment-là pour
éviter justement de tomber dans cette
routine qui était celle de prendre de
façon un peu automatique une cigarette
cette dimension comportementale dans
l'addiction est très importante et elle
fait véritablement partie de l'addiction
d'ailleurs les les fumeurs le savent
très bien puisque très fréquemment ils
sont les premiers à dire mais je ne sais
plus quoi faire de mes doigts depuis que
j'ai arrêté de fumer donc le fait
d'avoir un produit de le manipuler euh
bah ça fait partie de l'addiction c'est
difficile il faut il faut en avoir
conscience et il faut arriver quand on
est prêt à à rentrer dans cette phase de
sevrage à passer outre ses habitudes et
à essayer de les de les dominer mais
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut avoir un soutien par
un professionnel de santé éventuellement
ou et
surtout une substitution nicotinique qui
va déjà rendre la dépendance biologique
euh plus simple à affronter et donc si
déjà au niveau biologque
on
est apaisé j'ai envie de dire la
dimension comportementale on pourra la
combattre plus facilement c'est
important de se faire aider il y a aussi
certains fumeurs qui n'osent pas arrêter
de fumer parce que ils estiment que
s'ils arrêtent de fumer ils vont prendre
du poids puisque le goût et l'odorat
reviennent en arrêtant de fumer est-ce
que c'est
inéluctable la prise de poids non elle
est pas elle est pas obligatoire c'est
vrai
que un certain nombre de F fumeur au
moment où ils s'arrêent prennent du
poids ce qu'il faut voir c'est que la
cigarette agit comme un coupe fin donc
les fumeurs très souvent mangent moins
que que que que que les autres et donc
ils vont retrouver un appétit qui est un
petit qui qui est normal il y a
peut-être aussi une inactivité physique
donc c'est peut-être aussi le moment de
reprendre une activité physique c'est
peut-être aussi le moment de se reposer
la question de son alimentation de
l'équilibre de son alimentation et
surtout d'en parler avec le
professionnel qui va qui va suivre qui
va vous suivre dans ce sevrage ou avec
le tabacologue de tabac infoservice ou
de regarder euh le site de moi sans
tabac qui là aussi donne des conseils
donc il faut se reposer la question
essayer effectivement de réduire un peu
ses apports alimentaires euh quand on
est dans cette phase de de sevrage parce
que l'effet coupef disparaît et que d'un
seul coup on va manger un peu petit un
peu plus donc c'est effectivement
malheureusement quelque chose qui est
souvent constaté mais ça c'est une
période qui va même si on prend un peu
de poids on on se rend compte que dans
la durée ce poids est reperdu et donc on
va finalement retrouver un poids normal
ou le poids qu'on avait précédemment
donc il vaut mieux de toute façon
s'arrêter de fumer prendre quelques
kilos pendant une petite période que
continuer à fumer dans tous les cas
alors dernière question lu joseran on va
essayer de faire assez rapidement je le
disais en début d'interview il y a 12
millions de Français qui fument mais
seulement 146000 personnes qui se sont
inscrit sur le site moi sans tabac ça
semble être un peu dérisoire est-ce que
le mois sans tabac
fonctionne
le mois en tabac fonctionne 146000 c'est
déjà c'est c'est c'est déjà un peu plus
d'un % ça peut paraître faible mais
c'est déjà quand même quelque chose
important c'est un une période pendant
laquelle les sevrages sont plutôt
réussis avec de l'ordre de 25 % de
réussite de sevrage donc ce qui est déjà
pas mal et puis comme je vous le disais
c'est aussi une démarche positive de
s'arrêter ça sera peut-être pas novembre
sans tabac mais ça sera peut-être
décembre sans tabac janvier sans tabac
donc surtout il faut continuer cette
démarche positive et puis tout le monde
n'est pas prêt en même temps à s'arrêter
de fumer donc là il y a certains fumeurs
qui sont prêts qui sont inscrits qui
vont le faire et puis à ceux qui sont
pas inscrits qui vont le faire quand
même donc dans tous les cas en parler
avoir un focus sur le sevrage pendant un
mois c'est déjà une très bonne chose et
ça va entraîner des saevrages dans tous
les cas donc ça c'est une très bonne
chose pour tous ceux qui vont s'arrêter
et bien merci beaucoup loï joseran
d'avoir répondu à nos questions alors si
vous êtes fumeur n'hésitez pas à
demander de l'aide et à vous faire
accompagner vous pouvez notamment
télécharger l'application tabac
infoservice sur votre télé téléphone
portable ou appeler le numéro gratuit
3989 pour bénéficier de l'aide d'un
tabacologue et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci pour votre fidélité
demain rendez-vous avec grégoryi canalé
pour une nouvelle émission je vous
souhaite une belle soirée sur tv68 bon
courage à tous les fumeurs qui
souhaitent arrêter de fumer ce mois-ci
prenez soin de
[Musique]
vous